带一对
哎嗯对哈哈哈哈哈
♪ Ready ♪
♪ Oh i'm ready ♪
♪ One two ♪
♪ Ready go ♪
Easy easy
♪ 自己笑一笑 ♪
♪ 没什么大不了 ♪
Easy bp
♪ 神奇的宝子大气唱 ♪
再次来到上海
maybe冰要展开
一连三天
又是一个很开心的体能考验
什么什么东西呢
哦你找到男朋友了啊
小男友了
哎呀好好笑哦
这个是不是在这之前
他们有个三个一起啊
哎呀好危险哦
有费洛蒙
然后让我们产生了脑内飞觉得愉悦进步
一是我们都没有
你们没有
我们对我们真不漂亮吗
来来我们三个来
何德何能
哇哈哈哈哈
One two three four
请大摆上班开会
你们你们是不是可以坐这里呀
比较好玩
我的最佳啦啦队
我的气氛组真的很多粗卡诶
怎么办怎么办
要要哭吗
我们进啊
要哭吗
哈可以啊
不要西施效果吗
可以发自内心吗
我的天哪哈哈
他会把他踢走吧
他等会直接你要送海报
你要送海报
对诶
你要签名啦
好像蛮合的
是一样的吗
卧槽哈哈哈哈
我的第一张签名海报竟然是给小姐
你好幸运哦
哈哈开玩笑开玩笑一
很开心
很荣幸跟呃这个可爱的大家一起努力
马上就要完成这个SUGHAI的所有的旅程
蛮难得的
能够一路这样走到现在
非常荣幸
也非常感谢各位战友们
谢谢你们
今天是上海的最后一天
然后我们在一起一起努力
一起好好把握今天晚上
然后把最好的我们给内地的观众朋友
我应该是最幸运的观众
可以连续看70几场演唱会
你有这么好看这么好听
然后因为都在心灵身边
所以我知道要站上舞台
其实要克服很多很多的身心状况
所以我想说
谢谢
新年好
上海接着78
大家接着一路82026418
新的一年一定one2休
Sry
♪ 你出的主意馊主意超无敌疗愈 ♪
♪ 我掉进海里 ♪
♪ 深海里 ♪
♪ 你开来的船是铁达尼 ♪
♪ 我在了魔域中 ♪
♪ 需要去对 ♪
♪ 很漂亮吗 ♪
♪ 耶谢谢 ♪
这手套
我要买一组裙子
我也想要啊
他家给我穿
♪ 欢迎来cheing party ♪
♪ Cindy cindy cindy ♪
让你伤心
怎么可以肆意随地都快乐了
♪ 哈哈失恋失恋了按铃 ♪
谢谢你出的主意
♪ 做主 ♪
♪ 一场无敌疗愈海爱在一起 ♪
♪ 海浪海浪海浪来吧 ♪
太光明
♪ 哎海浪海浪海浪来吧 ♪
♪ 当你的眼睛眯着笑 ♪
♪ 当你喝可乐 ♪
♪ 当你吵 ♪
♪ 我想对你好 ♪
♪ 你从来不知道想你 ♪
想你也能成为我
我不会哭
哈哈哈赞嗯
谢谢在台上的每一位伙伴们喜欢
谢谢在幕后所有的工作同事们
谢谢来到现场
把时间留给我的每一位你们啊
啊今天不是今天不是告别啊
所以我本来不知道我会我
我希望我自己是一一个保持着一个嗯
对未来还有很多期待跟你们见面
期待的心情
但我没有想到在最后一刻还是有一点破防了
嗯重点是真的是很感动
SUHI1路走到今天77场啊
嗯在上海呃
第三天我觉得算是一个嗯圆满的圆满的
还说不是解说为圆满的一个嗯小阶段
哈哈哈啊
再次谢谢上海
谢谢所有来到现场的你们
有一点不想下台了
怎么办
♪ 可以让我再听听上海的声音在哪里 ♪
祝你们今天晚上都有一个甜甜的梦
♪ 愿星星伴你们入睡 ♪
♪ 晚安啦 ♪
♪ 亲爱的上海 ♪
相信我们很快会再见的
谢谢你们
♪ 谢谢 ♪
啊哈哈哈哈
我小时候我应该很坚强啊
是但是就是就是game到最后一刻
就当你还是有那个感觉hold不住呃
呃反正就是很很感谢大家的爱
拜拜台北见
好紧张好紧张好紧张
他爱人他爱人都很年轻
很多人哈哈哈哈哈哈
那你怎么有办法在台上讲
不要讲话
现在要讲话
他在发在发抖
疯狗不要让他讲话
哈哈跳舞的时候就不紧张
那别跳
你可以跳着说哈哈哈意外
然后你们一起做NBINNDI天下在上海
在上海
然后我会说everybody嗨起来
嗨嗨起来
好好跟大家对
所以我们等下要这样子吗
CYNDI甜心在上海
everybody嗨起来
Sugar sugar
嗨嗨嗨
谢谢谢谢谢
好好吃哈哈